welcome back to las vegas now time for
some
throwback thursday knowledge thanks to
jc and his sin
city chronicles
[Music]
here we go it's time for this week's sin
city chronicles
a weekly look back at vegas history and
happenings
let's start off by going back to
november 6 1993
when one of the most bizarre moments in
sports history took place
at caesar's palace it was riddick beau
fighting evander holyfield
and in the seventh round parachutist
james fan man miller
crashed into the ring causing a 21
minute delay
and somebody in a parachute has just
landed on the edge of the ring miller
was attacked by fans as you can see
and security guards he was actually
knocked out and had to be taken
to the hospital fan man was eventually
charged with dangerous flying
and was released on two hundred dollars
bail you know
a hotel implosion is good when they
showcase it in a movie
the landmark hotel was imploded on
november 7
1995 and the footage was used in the
1996
tim burton movie mars attacks
november 1944 mr showmanship arrived in
las vegas
liberace had his first vegas engagement
at the new frontier hotel
his salary was 750 a week
10 years later he was the highest paid
performer on the strip when he opened
the riviera
at 50 000 a week liberace passed away
in 1987
[Music]
rod stewart started performing in 1963
but he would not arrive in las vegas
until november 3rd 1984. that's when his
camouflage tour
came to the thomas and mack he closed
the show with his hit
maggie may and a couple decades later
stewart would become a vegas staple
with his residency at caesar's palace
those dance moves
he's got it down that's your sin city
chronicles for the first week of
november